you don't have to read comics to love
Thor Ragnarok because director Taika
Waititi and his crew have made such a
genuinely fun movie but for longtime
Marvel Comics fans it's even more
special because of all the hidden
goodies inside here are some of the
small references in Thor Ragnarok that
you might have missed and of course
spoilers ahead immigrant song Led
Zeppelin's immigrant song is the perfect
music to accompany a high-octane action
sequence like the ones at the beginning
and end of Thor Ragnarok even better the
lyrics fit perfectly Robert Plant and
Jimmy Page wrote the song after visiting
Iceland and being impressed with his
landscape and history and the songs full
of references to the same Scandinavian
mythology upon which the Thor comments
were based the line the hammer of the
gods as a reference to Thor's hammer
Mjolnir and of course when Robert Plant
kroons about Valhalla he's talking about
the realm of the honored warriors who
fell in battle
the Norse afterlife is left out of the
Thor movies but after the events of this
one Valhalla would be crowded with us
Guardians Gorgon meek Korg is a cronin
one of the stone men who were thoughts
very first enemies in his debut
appearance and the pages of journey into
mystery issue 83 Korg himself first
appeared as an individual character and
the Planet Hulk comic book story from
2006 that story also introduced meek a
weird little insect creature who turns
out to be surprisingly bloodthirsty in
the movie meek doesn't speak at all and
Korg played by director Tiger ytt is
much more soft-spoken than he seems in
the comic pull me off oh my god off the
ground
pulled me off the ground up into the air
and I would fly there fun characters but
if you only see the movie you won't have
a clue about Meeks original nature as a
character or corpse long comic book
history with Thor he's a thing of course
a Korg is far from the most famous Rock
man in Marvel Comics if our honor
unquestionably goes to Ben Grimm the
Fantastic Four member better known as
the thing the thing has a longer rivalry
with the Hulk in the comics but he can't
appear in movies with them because of
licensing agreements that's why it's
funny when Thor first meets Korg and
takes him for a pile of rocks and Korb
replies saying imagine a thing of being
for fans of Marvel Comics there's only
one image that pops into your head when
a rock man introduces himself as a thing
this guy Point Break
to activate the voice recognition
security system on the Quinjet Thor has
to refer to himself as Point Break a
callback to the nickname Tony Stark gave
him and the Avengers no hard feelings
Point Break you got a mean swing before
his haircut at Stan Lee's hands
Authority strong resemblance to Bodie
the character Patrick Swayze plays in
the 1991 film a Point Break panelist
Hulk waking up as Bruce Banner after
such a long time as the Hulk is
understandably jarring and it obviously
has a negative impact on Vanis psyche
this sort of thing also happened in the
comics a few times during the Planet
Hulk storyline bana rarely appears
because the planet is so dangerous the
most famous panelist Hulk storyline
however was published in 1988 The
Incredible Hulk issue 347 thanks to a
wizard spell the Hulk is freed of banner
and gets a job working for the mob in
Las Vegas he even begins wearing
tailored clothes in his own size rather
than banners torn pants and generally
lives the high life it's usually a mark
of these panelists Hulk stories that the
hoax speaks more and acts more
rationally the longer he stays himself
so it makes sense that he's relatively
talkative in Ragnarok sokovia forgotten
who even remembers sokovia when Bruce
Banner brings it up and asked what
happened to the city
Thor doesn't even answer he just points
out that the battle with Ultron happened
two years ago sure at the time of seeing
a city lifted into the sky by Ultron it
seemed like a huge earth-shaking deal it
played a part in the events of Captain
America's Civil War although even then
they barely followed up on what happened
there after the battle this exchange
between Banner and Thor conveys how long
a banner has been out of it but Thor's
reaction is also a bit of a joke about
how little the huge action sequences at
end each movie tend to matter once the
credits roll Fenris Ragnarok doesn't
explain much about Fenner mister wolf
he's treated mostly as an ally and bound
for the death goddess hella
interestingly in the comics and the
Norse myths on which they're based
Heller and fan risks are actually
straight-up siblings and their father is
none other than Loki in the movie Halla
becomes Odin's daughter and therefore
Loki's adopted sister while the wolf's
origin is left completely unexplained
but the closeness between hello and
Fenris and that green glow in his eyes
hints at their true relationship from
the comics valkyries digs she may look a
little different but the character
played by Tessa Thompson is very much
the same Valkyrie who has appeared in
Marvel Comics since the 1970s Valkyries
gold and silver armor and blue cape come
directly from the comics along with her
sword dragon Fang and the flying horse
but more than anything it's a
characterization that makes him
recognizable
Valkyrie is a swaggering hard-drinking
warrior woman who's worked hard to get
away from a long and troubled past
before eventually making peace with it
Thor's eye when Thor loses an eye in
battle with Heller and starts wearing an
eyepatch at the end of Thor Ragnarok
it's an obvious way of visually
depicting his transition into his
father's role as king of Asgard
since Odin was famously one-eyed as well
but it also resonates with a version of
Thor from the comics who bore an even
closer resemblance to Odin King Thor as
is often called is a version of Thor
from the future who first appeared in
Thor god of thunder issue one like so
many things in thor ragnarok it works
perfectly well if you haven't read the
comics but if you have it takes on even
more meaning thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love tea
[Music]